hi there Steve here again output how do
we start talking in a language I'm on my
polish ham challenge I spent the first
two months intensively listening and
reading probably in total over two hours
a day on average most of it is listening
but also reading and reading on link and
I showed you how I save words and
phrases when I'm on the computer I do
the same on the iPad I do it a little
differently on the iPad i alternate
perhaps 7080 percent the difficult
material that's of interest history and
so forth and 20% filters simple stories
where I tried to get at the nuts and
bolts of the language but I decided the
beginning in November that I would start
speaking and because I was unable to
find enough polish speakers at link who
wanted to offer discussions I went to I
talky so I have been using I talky and
basically since well for about a week
now so with I talky I'm trying to speak
once a day so that I speak either half
an hour or an hour with four or five
different polish tutors and I'm really
enjoying it so I find it it's a very
useful service I think perhaps our the
way we deal with with lessons you know
talking to tutor at link is a little
inflexible we need to maybe look at
making it more flexible at itok II the
teachers decide themselves how much
they're going to charge and you can
choose depending on the different prices
and which ones you like and and I think
that's a successful and it's a very good
complement to link because the bulk of
the activity for me the both of my
learning remains this this input
activity to build up my my vocabulary my
ability to understand and so forth and
as now I'm gonna finish off here with a
snippet of a recording with one of the
tutors at I talkie all of them are very
very pleasant Katarina doesn't have the
best sound so I sent them struggled to
understand her
some of the others have better sound but
yeah I tried to record some earlier and
I didn't have my thing set up properly
so this is basically me after about a
week of starting to talk in Polish I
make a lot of mistakes but I'm happy
making mistakes I know that in time I
will be better and so the I will do this
one is sort of the beginning of starting
to talk and I will do another video at
the end of the month when I will have
had quite a few hours of speaking and of
course continuing to listen and read
because a lot of what the conversation
does is it points out the gaps it makes
me aware of what I need to work on the
words I'm missing the structures I make
mistakes in and so I go back and I look
for these in my listening and reading
so with that you can have a listen I
didn't make subtitles because it's I'm
very busy down here if somebody wants to
translate it firing
otherwise basically we talk about
working conditions and how hours that
people work in Warsaw Paris and
Vancouver bye for now okay Jeanne
d'Albret Karolina another JAXA mash
didn't shake no yeah she's she's co PO
don't go ah he Mishka a chef philesha
yuk yuk so Ruth Mitch a men's a barroom
key right varoom keep rats
Vaishali Parisian yeah Mogi hmm oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah that oh yes probably
edit oh see Joseph can I do
alais yaki so Ruth nice image yen's a
party and someone's name at all
mashallah of course okay
and no yes sometimes awesome
within the practice runs most of the
bottle I'll turn is why don't you that's
my impact that I know I know I've got
Couture iam toora loora go Gina that
shoes my eyebrows my shoes nose now
okay chin Chin's chestnut I'm awesome
volume effect white bubbles net it's max
such as Max Factor okay ahh
mm-hmm oh yes nice little booze in 1890
mm-hmm and shared by you do shut up
horrible dinner tonight
Hey mm-hmm but you know I'll go yet
I would never use V no III know oh
that's Mina Mina okay okay we party
supplies like imposing it nicely
Posner booze now Oh No
Oona's cannot yeah miss lady oh god
named van Vancouver Toronto Montreal
nach name a Sachin I may occur Oh Debbie
on tape okay
allez du jour loogie
Sachin I own
yeah just near Vancouver song song you
g30
Pratt suyeong Rodney Rodney
mmm Fortnum lincom tag America pool not
yeah
tag not now Oona's squad name Jay Jay go
or East Coast that kid sure yet how you
say Meisner yesterday economic hand low
attack or or and love it he liked to go
ludis Vancouver's Zack Watney chat chest
doc odine Pratt's Ohio a squad a moose
on those touch Bureau Debbie on Tam
Debbie on Tamaran oh oh yeah those notch
a shoot them
rano Vancouver aha so an apricot bearish
is a beat again how do you say stock
market and in fact ah Tampa Gilda that
you know they want them New York a lot a
go Ludi Vancouver cattle prod three
homes skilled um Busan starch
Bureau Shifta Schuster ID lutely the
ludic stories at nigh on chest chest
nada early testing that's me chase yeah
only conch I just named canta canta our
roots on duty on say Oh rotten brats I
owe Domo Jardim doc ah Yugi Tory Tory
Praetorian Vancouver cake yeah Moochie
own sake not chest chest chest not only
brats I own normal dark piata the toy I
said nuts them how would I say no I
Tara's match granya duck recording
conch koncham a
for them Benjy a continuous rod move yet
a movie okay